wide open clear skies and with highs
only in the mid 50s yesterday that's
allowed temperatures
to just keep on dropping until we get to
sunrise which is
right now it is 39 degrees out there
it's gorgeous but cold oh my goodness
you've got to grab a nice warm coat
jacket might even need gloves if you're
going to be out for a while
in the cold air and we're already down
to 39 in laughlin we rarely get
chilly temperatures like that too often
down the river in laughlin 28 in perum
perhaps
red rocks down to 27. we're near
freezing in mesquite and already below
freezing in kingman at 27.
boulder city are right in the mid 30s
right now so 55 yesterday we'll go up a
few degrees today
closer to 60 degrees but still a full 10
degrees below normal last week
we were setting record highs this week
setting records for
extra cold highs at 55 yesterday so near
60 today that sunrise 613
and we'll be again just around 4 30 even
though it's
after 4 30 the official sunset time that
sun's gone by 4 30.
lots of deep cold over the great basin
in the desert southwest
some snow showers around denver but that
cold is sweeping into the midwest
and the ohio valley later today so
there's another system out here in the
pacific
it will move in after veterans day bring
us a lot of cloud cover
and also another chance for snow in our
local mountains by thursday
i don't know so much about rain for the
valley they're getting good rain today
over wisconsin headed towards the great
lakes and let's get down to ada a
tropical storm it's pulled away from
southern florida
it's going to sit in the eastern gulf of
mexico and continue on a northerly path
back to florida by the end of the
weekend as a tropical low
depression my goodness i can't believe
it's still it's just sitting there
living it's staying alive
all right 62 degrees for veterans day
cool but beautiful sunshine
clouds for thursday we just inch our way
into the mid 60s by the end of the week
and then we'll look for it maybe even
low 70s alex by monday so eventually we
do pull out of the deep freeze
early next week